we were talking earlier about cultural
Decay and societal Decay we were talking
about how um
was it Jack fasovic his neighborhood was
falling apart he's never gonna he hasn't
brought his kids back to see his
childhood home welcome to Milf Manor the
most repulsive exploitative sorted hate
to Hate show of all time where
blindfolded moms rubbed down shirtless
sons and TV finally hits Rock Bottom
this is uh MILF MILF Manor where moms go
and get a bunch of sons and they rub
them this is a 30 Rock joke on 30 Rock
they made MILF Island and they're
actually doing the show right now and
then I want to give a special shout out
to Dana White for power slap yeah Power
slap said to have its pay-per-view debut
in March with the League's success this
is the show where people slap each other
in the face I take turns to do it and
it's like you gotta not get knocked down
and get back up or something this is
literally on my balls have you guys have
you guys seen Idiocracy an idiocracy
it's uh Luke Wilson it's a research
experiment for hibernation they forget
about him it's funny it's Mike Judge and
then he wakes up 500 years in the future
he goes to some guy's house and then is
there something is there audio playing
oh there is and then uh yeah they're
cheering for the slap fight and then uh
he's watching a show called out my balls
and it's literally a guy who's just like
he falls on a fence goes oh my balls and
then like someone throws a football and
goes oh ow my balls and that's the whole
show and then the guy's watching
this is that I'm sorry dude this is
jackass without the stunts pretty much
on my balls you see you see the clips
from this where people just they go and
they have seizures dude we gotta we
gotta play at least one the the one
where the guy's face is huge on the left
side this one this guy so what they're
doing is they're standing with their
arms behind their back about two feet
away from each other across a table and
they are not allowed to guard or defend
that's the thing about boxing that's
legit is you can defend yourself you
can't defend yourself in the sport and
then they just take CTE they take yeah
Palm bone to the face over and over
until they fall down and go
unconsciously look at this guy's face
man like this guy's taking multiple
shots to the side of the head that's why
his head looks like this the thing is
like and they have us as well as like
apparently it's a sport in in Eastern
Europe or something like that where I
don't know where it originated no idea
but they don't step into it they just
stand and slap it exactly and then they
take a full step and can turn their
whole body and get their whole way
behind it and it's so much more foreign
about it how do you win like you just
they go back and forth and they hit each
other until someone can't stand anymore
until someone either bows out or gets
knocked down and is this like is this
like with UFC there's like weight
classes right like do you pair people up
based on size or is it random like no
idea but I don't think so there's a
women's division I saw two I haven't
seen a guy in a woman yet
do they actually show yeah I'm sure they
will hear right in the beginning and
they're like highlighting these gruesome
knockouts
welcome to powerslap from the fight
capital of the World Las Vegas Nevada
it's not really a sport that we're about
to be in
the world no it won't this is so dumb
and I'll be able to be a Pioneer within
this sport I've been through a lot in my
life growing up on the streets so I deal
with African streets there ain't gonna
be no chance of me quitting I was
brought up in a quite rough area so yeah
I've had to look after myself a few
times I think that'll help the
competition
I just grew up tough yeah you know so I
want somebody that thinks they have
something to come fuel all this rage and
all this pain in this hand because I
will put it in their face
I came out here to do one job and one
job only and that's to put on the show
but I'm Gladiator
I heard people that's what I do nobody
touched me I'm untouchable baby you go
remember my name
this is where we're gonna separate the
men from the boys the hardest hitters a
lot of trash talking a lot of energy
from start to finish
I don't care who you are I gotta say I'm
a huge fan of Dana White the UFC I love
it all this show just is really
confusing
you got the song
[Applause]
oh yeah he's totally wound up oh yes
he's just knockout porn dude yeah
that's all it is yeah the doctor's
coming in there this guy's gonna have a
CTE this guy's gonna have a truck hey
now we are doing this for free on World
Star Hip Hop
how is what I don't get it what is this
it's it's a it's a bastardization of
something that is already popular that
Dana Weiss yeah I was gonna say all of
this reminds me of UFC yeah just except
for the actual contact oh it's when they
get that the Palm bone across the cheek
jaw it's like the work critical yeah but
look like in in UFC and MMA people they
fight they block they defend they make
mistakes it's like it's like uh uh it's
a sport it's a chess the strategy yeah
this is stand still I'm gonna try and
hit you as hard as I can and you're
gonna get hit someone tweeted out what
is it next like see who can survive a
stabbing the best
eventually if you ever watch the show
How I Met Your Mother they had like a
slap bat right and like if you lose the
bet you like one character gets to hit
the other one as hard as you can like
whenever and it's like that cross UFC
like I don't I don't understand why this
would be fun also like are they gonna
try to do like the uh wrestling thing
where they're like oh these two have a
rivalry because he hit him really hard
in the face like I got it it's just
weird you guys ever played doorknob when
you were young someone farts and then
you punch him in the shoulder or
something no no until they touch it or
not exactly you yell doorknob and then
you're allowed to hit him in the arm
until they touch the doorknob or they
fart and say safety and you can't call
doorknob that's the game we get a bunch
of guys in a ring and they're all
standing around the pipeline and then
everyone's got to eat a can of beans an
hour before the event and then you're
standing there and then as soon as
someone hears it everyone everyone yells
doorknob and then you'll hear the Guy
Yell safety and then like the timer will
call and be like it's good and they'll
go Oh They'll all start running and
start wailing on the guy trying to get
to the doorknob but the doorknob's on a
string and it's swinging
somebody pulls a card in like the
doorknob's in the Box you got to open
boxes
that would be more Artful than this yeah
honestly like there's got to be some
kind of skill component it can't just be
who can get the critical hit like
seriously how do you train for this it
goes first like do you train to fall
down or do you train to slap or like
because if you're trained as a member in
South Park when Cartman would be like
let's Rochambeau for it it's like what
is that first I kick you in the balls
yeah then you kick me in the balls and
whoever's Still Standing wins yeah who
goes first and then he goes I'll go
first and then he kicks him and so like
if you're training in power slap I would
imagine you're training your sparring
partner they call it sparring isn't
going to try and break your face because
you're going into perform pretty soon so
there might I can't imagine that they're
going as full form so how can you
possibly prepare for something oh no
because then we thought we have hard
sparring too and you know so it depends
like you know if you're a light Spar
maybe you're just focused on like the
technical maybe it's just the fingers
just tip but maybe if your heart's born
you know you like give them some full
Palm action you know you like to get
real deep in there on the
I don't know man this is
this is what we're reduced to like we're
having uh we're having philosophical
conversations American Gladiators was
was like agility who was that Bill Hicks
he react on American Gladiators he's
like here is 68 channels of it or
whatever
it's like we made fun of it but that
they had padding and they had those big
Q-tip things and they were like trying
to knock each other in the foam pit
right at least that was fun and silly
and no one really got hurt American
Ninja Warrior I love American Ninja
Warrior right yeah that's fascinating
you know what I don't like about
American Ninja Warrior it's not fair to
women oh yeah the upper body strength
requirements it's not that it's the the
what is it called the spider walk or
whatever the wall it's two walls and you
have to jump into it and put your hands
if you're tall with a with a large arm
span no problem but there are women who
are really good really fit with great
upper body strength and their hands just
don't reach and I'm like how are they
supposed to do it their hands don't
reach that's dumb but this gives them a
chance to have it to be Innovative and
like figure out how to get through it
and then the first one that does it were
like wow she was so sideways yeah
exactly sideways put her back like I
don't care I feel like yeah that's true
and it's it's fair to acknowledge it but
like it's a chance for her to really
overcome true uh I shouldn't say unfair
to women it's unfair to people with
smaller stature or shorter arms but
there tends to be the women because I'm
watching I watched one where the woman
she her fingers touch the edge and just
Falls and it's like she tried like yeah
what are they supposed to do if they
like readjust the wall so they're closer
it's like slightly unfair to all the
other competitors like that's what I
liked about American Ninja Warrior so
they just sent anyone down that thing
and like it doesn't matter who you are
and like some people struggle on some
things other people struggle on other
parts of the course like it's
fascinating to watch because it just
depends on I don't know maybe we should
make the doorknob show
and it's like two guys going to a ring
one hour after eating a can of Bush's
Baked Beans they're just like they're
like they're they're waiting and they
have like boxing gloves yeah but you
can't strike the opponent until they
fart and you call doorknob or but if
they call safety you can't and then you
know that'd be great you know that's
that's where we're headed I'm waiting on
this this is this is actually going to
be gold but this is the next big thing
people are gonna hang out at bars and be
like you want to put on doorknob like
you know me and my I used to play that
when I was a kid I'm having a hard time
saying this but I want to talk about
MILF Island
back to True culture yeah yes back to my
what I understand MILF Manor is weird
what is it okay I have just read very
little about it but like it's a bunch of
women who you might consider cougars
like they're moms all of them have to be
and they go to I assume you would
consider them a cougar I'm not an expert
you go to like Mecca they were filming
in Mexico but one of the requirements is
that they bring one of their single Sons
so like their son is living with all
these guys they're sort of weirdly group
dating because as a culture we've
decided that's something we're into and
like therefore like I I saw one clip of
it and this one mom is like careful
ladies am I asleep with your son
like I just don't like it it's so creepy
so like if if your mom is single and you
have a brother who's also single they
could go on this show but your brother
will be living with all these guys who
are kind of trying to sleep with your
mom bro like imagine imagine that you're
going to school and you find out that
your mom is on the show oh and like
you're getting roasted in the class
you're getting roasted in the glass and
you you have like one good clap back and
they say but your mom was on MILF Island
like what do you even say about that
like what do you say you just hang
around and shame and then go to a
different school like or I want to be
like my mom ran Mill filing
you would be like go Mom I'm proud of my
life yeah or like in all seriousness you
can be like yeah well at least she won
like how do you win I don't know but
what's winning this year off the island
for everybody yeah I can't believe this
is so what they they bring they each
bring a son and then they pass their
sons around to others yeah that's it
I've never seen a full episode but like
it's like what were those things called
where uh the swinger parties they would
bring up they put all their keys in a
bowl yeah white parties I think that's
what was it called white parties or put
all your keys in a bowl and then they
mix them together when you're leaving
you grab it and white parties might be
Coke parties yeah probably probably that
this was yeah I almost went to one of
the swinger parties I almost went to one
with this girl in LA and I just I never
did it's kind of weird
this one seems particularly weird
because like what conversations are you
guys having where it's like come on John
please come on the show like Mommy
really needs to meet a younger man it's
probably from the people from the porn
generation that saw porn when they were
kids they were raised when they were 11
and 12 watched MILF porn probably the
producers of the show watched MILF porn
when they were in their you know when
they were I want to be in that boardroom
and I want to figure out what those
people were on man because they they
were on the good good let's let's let's
just switch something a little bit more
wholesome have you guys seen
professional tag yeah that's fun it's
like an obstacle course and like one
guy's got to get away from the other guy
and he's running around and you know
that's fun they're like jumping through
obstacles and swinging through bars and
the guy's just trying to touch him
that's fun yeah we got we gotta have a
professional Red Rover or something that
would be so cool I don't know how you
gotta have like the Tim cats variety and
like game show where like every time you
just come up with like a new game show
like every week we could totally do that
at the new studio because we have that
big Builder I was thinking of a game
called do you want to live where you
do you want to live and it's like base
it's a joke about the Canadian assisted
suicide stuff where like people come in
and they're suicidal you're like well do
you and then you you get them all
inspired but then the skit would be like
at the end of the show like the family
comes in like so thank you so much I
love my life and at the end like yeah I
just thought about it but I still want
to I still want to kill myself I'm going
through with it you know guys what you
do is so um I watched this thing and
said that every person who jumped off
the Golden Gate Bridge and survived yeah
I regretted it said that they yeah they
regretted it they realized and then as
soon as they jumped the first thing they
thought was that all of life's problems
could be solved except having just
jumped off this bridge so that means
people who didn't make it were in regret
so you take people who are looking for a
maid and then you you make life flash
Before Their Eyes in a manner of
speaking and then they're also like I
love life you know it's like in a fight
club member and Fight Club when uh he he
Tyler Durden holds up the the liquor
store guy oh yeah and he's like Raymond
what is it K hassle what did you want to
be and he's like vegetarian he's like
and why aren't you too hard and then he
says something really awful that I'm not
gonna repeat because it's when I run you
know family friendly show and then he's
like I know where you live if you're not
on your way to becoming a vet I will
come to your house or whatever and then
he runs and then Edward Norton's like
why would you do that what's the point
and he's like tomorrow Raymond castles
breakfast will be the most delicious
meal he's ever tasted and it's yeah can
I go back to milk Manor for a second
sorry yeah please family friendly
something just crossed my mind
um they couldn't make this show in
Reverse it couldn't be like Dil like
dad's Island right like you're a single
dad but you have a single daughter and
you guys come to the island and then or
if it was called Date each other they
identify as MILFs though then it's okay
but you know what I'm saying like if it
was dads and daughters like creepy
everyone would be creeped out it was so
weird the dads would get angry with each
other hopefully you got to give it 10
years
it probably wouldn't do well if it was
called like young studs too if it was
focused on the young guys they were
gonna get laid with the older women that
might not play as as heartily as like
we're doing this for the ladies like
this is all about strengthening women in
our society yeah I just don't like this
at all that's weird also like
gamification of porn man yeah that's a
good way of putting it I just feel like
if it's creepy if you made it adult men
and younger girls like it should you
should also see it as creepy if it's
older women and younger men it's not
just Epstein's Island at that point
no we were I was I was talking about how
we're going to do like a a morning show
that's news
kind of like the view but with sane
women because uh I we've had we've got
you know women who work here moms and
then other people who have asked like is
there is there some way there can be a
show that's like Mom's talking about
issues that matter to them in politics
and culture because the views certainly
ain't it and then I was like we could
totally do it we've got we've got a
bunch of uh uh people that come in and
out of the show who are friends of ours
that are guests that are our moms that
talk politics that are sane moderate to
slightly conservative or libertarian
even a little liberal sounds good
someone just super chatted uh scrubby
mcgruberson says please name the morning
Mom news show MILF cast IRL
I appreciate the Super Chat because that
was a good one that was a good one I
actually am really excited for the new
space and they're hard at work on it but
we can totally do fun little game show
things I'm down for that we should we
should we should totally do with cast
Castle have like weird contests yeah
hole in the wall I was a huge fan of
that game yeah that's so cool they'd be
standing on like a moving platform and
the wall would be moving towards them
but there would be like a cut out on the
wall of a body yeah they have to make
the same position and like stand in the
right spot or they get pushed off the
platform and it's so funny they'll like
turn at the last minute they're like ah
because they realize like three feet off
and they're trying to modulate and yeah
we should think of the weird stuff we
can do like that's that's not vulgar and
just disturbing mxc yeah no I mean
what's that you know we could do mxc
like like Red Rover contest or something
you can't really do a Red Rover because
it's not really a game and we close on
the dude hard and that game it was uh
Tom I don't remember his last name we
could do I hope you're okay Tom Pro
Freeze tags for 35 years ago
yeah that'd be so fun yeah part of like
entertaining stuff is like
I think so many people who make
entertainment right now are like it has
to either be sexual or it has to be
super violent and actually like what's
entertaining is seeing people like try
hard you know what I mean like with uh
American Ninja Warrior like Pro freeze
tag like people are trying to accomplish
something and like we we like that we
root for people who are trying to like
achieve yeah you see somebody somebody
uh super chatted saying Delph this is uh
Heron gaming saying Delph Island would
be two shows in one it would become an
MMA show yeah
so how about dilf Island this actually
this would be a really great scratch a
really great sketch where it's like 10
MMA fighters with 20 year old daughters
and they're all brought in and it's just
all the dudes
he's trying to talk to this girl but
also he's designed his daughter and that
other guy who's talking to her like it'd
be terrifying that is actually a great
show but also like all the men would be
accused of being super creepy and like I
think that should apply to these women
who are like you're the same age as my
son great and they're rubbing their
chest like what it's ridiculous yeah
super weird we live in a weird weird
Society this is why I'm like cultural
Decay man look they're rebooting King of
the Hill really not rebooting they're
restarting it they're doing New Seasons
and like Brittany Murphy who voiced
luanne's not around anymore and what
Bobby Hill is going to be the same
little kid or something they're uh
they're uh doing us a new Frasier it's
just everything I thought he already got
a spin-off Frasier it was a spin-off of
cheers and then now they're doing
another one and it's just like they keep
remaking things they're out of ideas
Netflix is buying canceled shows and
then restarting them it's like do we
have anything left as a society are
humans just stagnant and bored well I
think they also don't want to take the
risk right like if you put a new show
out there then you are like opening
yourself up to cancel if I recycle old
material that at one point you were kind
of okay with I'm protecting myself a
little bit I don't like it uh but that's
why I have to watch all the Fast and
Furious movies because I was like very
anti-sequel and then I lost a bet on
popcorn have you seen any of them I'm up
to five I think I've seen one through
five but I have to get to nine before
the next one are you actually like
registering what's happening or you just
have them on I watch them and I take
notes so I can like report live it's the
most intense journalism I've ever done
yeah but like I if you love car movies
yeah I get why you're into it I am not
into them so I don't tend to become very
invested in that like Fast and Furious
yeah I'm fast Cinematic Universe yeah no
I I disagree we went to outer space
cars out of planes and we were like whoa
this is amazing now they got cars they
could have done that they could have
done that in a different movie with
different characters and we would have
been like whoa cars in space
it's the evolution of the movie series
that makes it so amazing it's like every
every movie they do they add something
to it and now that they're going on to
like what is the episode 10 or whatever
they already went to outer space I'm
ready to see Vin Diesel get super powers
yeah no yes
shrinks down his car and goes into a
guy's body and then he has to shrink
down his car and chase him through the
veins they're like driving on the veins
they're like Fantastic Voyage but you
know the movie where the guy goes He
shrinks down except but like you have a
villain element to it in your space he
was like a white blood cell that he went
through the body I just want to know if
the 10th movie there's a Tesla because
that seems like it makes sense to me
Elon Musk has got to be in it like I've
never thought about cars so much in my
life as I here's what I I'll watch this
franchise
free a bunch of slaves I will I will
personally Lobby any production house or
whoever's gonna fund this for the next
Fast and Furious movie Vin Diesel and
the crew are are driving they're testing
an experimental new car
with like a fusion you know plasma
reactor that explodes and the energy
hits all of them and they all get a
different superpower and then but one of
them turns bad and that like Dr Doom and
then you know they're fighting and like
Vin Diesel is like super strong and can
jump really high and he like punches the
ground and the ground explodes and well
the other guy can shoot lightning from
his fingertips one guy gets like because
when they get knocked out of the car
like one guy gets the gasoline gets on
him and he gets lit on fire so he gets
like fire powers one guy's like it's hit
by the airbag so he becomes like wind
power you know one guy's like stuck
under the tires so he gets you know
ground power yeah he turns into a rubber
man yeah he's rolling 20 on that one you
could have like the villain could stuck
with a bunch of the carbon dioxide from
the exhaust and he's like breathing it
in no he's taking them all smoke yeah
so like there's like black smoke coming
off him when he walks and he's like
whatever happened to me was a gift
and then videos is like no I think it's
blasted away and then Michelle Rodriguez
is like
it's just like not the same franchise at
all like it's not now it went down
just make a different movie about this
no no you realize when you play games
like um software Inc you that you can
buy IPS so I could buy like an old movie
and then put that name on my movie that
has nothing to do with it and it'll just
sell more tickets I get I get that there
is just a cult following there's
something about this I'll never totally
follow Ludacris gets the ability to like
interface with machines because that's
his character he's like The Tech Guy no
that made me mad because when I watched
I think he's like he smashed into the
car he's plugging in the USB right as
the the blast hits him
you take no man sir now yeah exactly and
then all of a sudden he's like I can see
and he's like Neo and he goes like this
and then like the car moves and he's
like
I am the cortex see that annoyed me he
was like I think it's like the fourth or
the fifth one I just watched it recently
like he was like this nice guy with an
afro and he waves the flags and he
collects the money but then they wanted
to bring him back so they're like we
gotta give you something to do he built
a spaceship you know how to unlock the
Vault I haven't seen that one yet don't
ruin it before the spaceship man he went
out his face with it I knew he had it in
him like I just don't get it like why
why is this the trajectory but I
realized that and think about think
about it I have a lot more to go like
whatever they're on 10 I think and then
but look they already the superpowers
are already in it I've talked about this
in Hobbs and Shaw which is a spin-off
Idris elba's a super soldier
cybernetically enhanced he's like
bulletproof or something
I'm I'm totally Davis and then in the
11th when they fight Transformers then
you bring Optimus Prime and and you know
in it and then it's you know it makes
perfect sense it writes itself you keep
it going into absurdity it would
actually kill because
imagine this imagine Optimus Prime has
got a blade through his chest and he's
like Dom you must stop Megatron and then
Megatron's like no in swings and then
Dom they both punch and there's like
little Dom and big Megatron their fists
are like
and that's the trailer I would spend 50
bucks to see that movie yeah and you all
would too everybody knows it
and this is for my new family yeah
he has to mention family a bunch of
times always always I felt bad for him
when he was like on the run with his
sister and her new boyfriend who's also
a Fed who like got you convicted for a
car or whatever
old enemies become friends when it's
confused at all have you seen any of
these just Hobbs and Shaw
um too much just talking about the Idris
Elba let me tell you you're missing a
lot of DJs so none at all well it makes
me actually angry to think about how
they'll never make a fun movie like that
like think about think think about the
Spider-Man movie they did was it no way
home no which what which one was it was
it no way home where uh Toby McGuire and
Andrew Garfield were in it was in it
yeah that's a new one no way home I
think I think so and it was it was
awesome to see like the they rebooted
Spider-Man but they just twice so they
just had to bring the other character to
say it's like a Multiverse and it was it
was fun and it was funny and it was cool
to see that they brought these other
characters back even though they're
completely different movie franchises
and the rumor is for uh the new so they
did Infinity War where all the Marvel
movies come together the rumor is
they're going to do Secret Wars which is
a multiversal saga from Marvel so
they're apparently going to bring in
Hugh Jackman from the X-Men movies into
the MCU and have all these different
characters from different movies in one
I think that's a fantastic idea yeah I
want to see Dom in Fast and Furious
swing a fist with Meg with Megatron and
they and they stop and like energy
bursts out and you know Optimus Prime is
there is it the actual Transformers they
get the rights I don't know who owns it
is it Universal don't they own both I'm
pretty sure there's just not a few yeah
look up look up who owns both how would
you make it better
it totally is I know probably like a
woman who falls in love with a guy he's
a vampire or something no that's rude
I'd make it a Hallmarks movie
softer Optimus Prime is if it's a
Christmas small town a small town robot
who runs shirts as a truck driver and
when Dom brings his cousin back she's
got a busy business boyfriend who's the
worst who's the worst and she falls in
love with Optimus and realize she never
left her hometown and then down fight
the Megatron okay I'll think about it
that's better no I mean I guess for me
this like I also am not super into the
MCU or like the DC thing where it's like
here's 87 characters and movies and like
I just feel like the plot gets lost but
I recognize that this is a personal like
I just am not into it well look don't
worry about all the characters because
eventually you're going to watch so much
much Fast and Furious that every
character is just going to be Dom on the
screen back they all are they're all
versions of Dom it's very weird oh
really yeah also things don't make
don't mean we're just supposed to accept
it yeah thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time